hi friends today my guest is Robin Drake
and he is the ex head of the FBI's
Behavioral Science Division now that
sounds like an incredibly secretive and
exciting job to have it really is
today's discussion takes us through
Robins 21 year in field career including
when he was in Manhattan on 9/11 he was
out for coffee with his friend as the
first plane struck the North Tower and
then back on the 25th floor of his
department when the second plane hit
apart from that we're also going to
learn the verbal and nonverbal cues that
both you can use to help encourage trust
and make your communication with others
more effective and also to be able to
detect deception in other people Robin
really is the real deal
it's evident that he has a very
terrifying and wide-ranging skill set of
personal and interpersonal communication
I'm super happy to have him on I'm not
gonna pontificate anymore
please welcome Robin Drake oh yeah PS we
did have some connection issues during
this episode I promised that any of the
cuts I made weren't due to Robin given
away national secrets and also the irony
of a podcast about communication being
beset with communication problems is not
lost but there may be a couple of jumps
here and there so just bear that in mind
[Music]
so Robin is this the moment where the
FBI first in through the door of my
bedroom and tell me that we need to stop
this no cuz I duck and we've really well
and you're on the other side of the
screen so you're gonna be fine well
anyway thank you very much for coming on
welcome to modern wisdom it's a pleasure
our view here Thanks thanks for having
me I'm excited about it as well it's
gonna be a great great conversation so
can you tell the listeners at home what
your job roles were please sure so I'll
kind of give you a chronology from the
beginning to the end without taking a
million million million minutes to do
this just cuz it's not boring but it's
good to frame the background of where I
came from to where I arrived and where
I'm still going to and that is so my
background is I graduated from the
United States Naval Academy here in
Annapolis Maryland
and from there went on to become a
Marine Corps officer and from there I
joined the FBI and I joined the FBI in
1997 and worked counterintelligence for
my entire career so I was assigned to
New York field office in Manhattan from
there I went to Norfolk Virginia from
Norfolk Virginia I went into management
so I went up to the Jay Edgar Hoover
Building here in Washington DC
also during out my entire career I
worked Russians so that's kind of the
the nouveau thing these days although
for 21 years don't was listening to me
and so and so when I started running the
behavioral now you know the program at
headquarters there my time in New York
before I got there I got on our
behavioral analysis program for
counterintelligence and what the
behavioral analysis program is and a lot
of people know about the profilers and
the behavioral analysis units from
things like Criminal Minds and movies
like that there was a criminal guys the
guys who work on criminal cases my team
we were nothing but counterintelligence
cases and my team's whole strategy all
the time was how we're going to create a
good healthy engagement with another
human being whether you're trying to
recruit a spy talk to someone interview
someone whatever it is we were always
strategizing engagements and so from FBI
headquarters I eventually escaped thank
God because I'm not a I'm not a
headquarters guy realized and
asked me to go down to Quantico where I
taught counterintelligence interviewing
and source recruiting and things like
that and then I took over our behavioral
team as the head of it back in 2010 ish
and I ran it for three or four years
until sequestration which was a big
budget thing we had eliminated my team
and a bunch of things and so I went back
down to the street and I worked as an
agent on the street working
counterintelligence from the hospital
years before I retired so yeah my entire
career has been nothing about trying to
recruit spies catching spies talking to
sources all nothing but Intel all the
time right I mean that sounds like this
stuff novels are made of right there's a
lot of Psych kind of the typical spice
that sounds like the proper James Bunch
it it is it is you know straight funny
and I actually you know you'd be in the
UK is really great I have a saying with
special I was in New York I love love
working with the Queen because we we
worked with mi5 and mi6 a lot and I love
them a lot because their funding was
always better than ours and they're
great hosts very very great hosts that's
awesome well I you know I think the
Brits are pretty well renowned for the
fact we have good tea and you know the
weather's not so good but everything
else that wasn't what we're that wasn't
what we were drinking yeah so you've
mentioned there some you know New York
field office in Manhattan and the J
Edgar Hoover Building those are places
that I really only know as references
for movies but that sounds like a sort
of place where there's an awful lot
going on a pretty big hub of activity
I'm gonna guess yeah but you know I
always you know I'm always I mean just
think about this people are generally
under and pressed with their own jobs
it's you know it's always it's always
the outside optic you know for me it was
my job basically my job was to build a
relationship to build trust yeah I got
you and so what was interesting was you
know a lot of people so you know I wound
up writing a bunch of articles and I
wrote a couple books I got another one
coming out this week year and my my
intro to whatever I'm doing a speech a
talk you know podcast or even in my
writing it always starts out with me
kind of laying out that background of
mine which says wow this guy is a type
hard-charging guy okay and say
absolutely right the problem is if you
want to recruit spies you're going to
fail majestically would that be and with
that kind of behavior of profile okay so
take us take us through what that means
and why that's the case
sure well and this is how I've really
related to business with all the
companies I work with because I called
my job the most challenging one in sales
because it was literally the toughest
sales job I think anyone could have and
that's what I have always run in
transition and I talked to a lot of
groups outside the FBI obviously that's
all I talked to now this is how I line
it out because when I was in New York my
job is to recruit spice here's what that
meant first of all you know I'm selling
a concept to someone from a foreign
country and the concept I'm selling is
that help in the United States is really
a good idea and even though it's might
not be in your best interest for your
country it's in the best interest of my
country so first of all I'm selling a
concept an idea that helping and
cooperating with me is a great idea so
that's that's so that's my product the
second most challenging thing now is
it's actually illegal for me as FBI to
walk up and talk to a foreign diplomat
because all the spies are foreign
diplomats under diplomatic cover and by
treaty it's actually illegal for me to
approach them so if my client that I'm
trying to sell this product to one
doesn't really care for my product -
it's illegal for me to actually contact
them about my product that that's your
first challenge does it cover the big
barrier is there
yeah really are and and the other thing
so if you can't talk to them directly
you're gonna maybe try to sell through
third parties you know some of their
contacts and you know in law enforcement
I love to say you know this this an out
because most people that work in law
enforcement there's a reason why people
have to talk to them they've done
something illegal so there's a
compulsion but when you work in the
world of counterintelligence very rarely
have people done something illegal you
know this takes pies for instance you
know it doesn't matter what country
they're in all they're doing is
collecting intelligence and what
generally is intelligence well it's
actually reading things in the newspaper
hearing things on the news or or looking
at a blog or something like this and so
you get
in information and now your next job is
is to source that information to people
in the know so say they read something a
newspaper they read a blog they see a
posting well now they're gonna go to
like the president of a clear the funds
contractor another diplomat someone from
a think-tank that they can say what do
you think about this now they get their
opinion on it well now that penny in has
sourcing now sourcing becomes
intelligence and none of that's illegal
and so there's no compulsion for them to
want to talk to me because they've done
nothing illegal it's illegal for me to
talk to them they don't want to buy my
product and now I want to talk to people
that are around them and the people
around them that are talking to they're
not doing anything illegal either and so
yes I want to quickly realize you know
when you're in your late twenties and
you have this hardcore type of
personality is if you approach people
with that kind of personality that don't
have any reason why they should want to
talk to you you're going to get shut
down really fast and so that was my
background so luckily for me though I
was on a squad of people that were my
Jedi Masters you know one in particular
his name is John you know he had this
art form down and just give me an
example you know in my line of work or
my previous line of work getting you
know actually recruiting a spy from
another country to cooperate with us and
give us all the jewels of the kingdom
it's it's like hitting lotto it's that
rare and it's that beneficial when it
does you know or winning you know
winning the sweepstakes yeah and when
you do it's it's extremely beneficial so
I always viewed my job every day is like
buying a lotto ticket I create
operations that give me an opportunity
to hit lotto
yeah or hit that sweepstakes and you
know unbeknownst to me one of the guys
on that I was working with that became
my mentor guide and and really my best
friend he had hit a lot of 14 times in
his career yeah no kidding and it was
really dumbfound because I never knew
that for years just because one of the
one of his great tenants of life is he
lived with great humility and humbleness
he never made it about him his desk at
work that had no I love me trophies or
posters on it um it was always about
everyone else but himself and that was
really the key you know I started
modeling my behavior I tried to after
him and then when I saw
when people start asking me to teach
this that was the first time I actually
had to take my friend John's art form of
interpersonal communication and make it
a paint-by-numbers so it could be
replicated
yeah and that's and that's twirl to
started getting born that's so
fascinating I mean it very quickly goes
away from being look and goes on the
scale when you win the lottery 14 times
right yeah yeah so there's no luck
involved this yeah it's for point to it
but did you have a background in
psychology or in any sort of behavioral
sciences before you went to the FBI no
actually you know my background was
leadership from the Marine Corps
um without realizing I was getting this
art performed better by the time I'd
gotten out
um came in the FBI and actually it was
very helpful because I had all these I
probably had about 15 15 17 years of
field experience doing this before
actually worked on my graduate work in
organizational psychology and so I
started seeing the science behind why
everything I was doing in the field was
working so instead of learning so
instead of having the education first
and then trying to apply it in limited
situations I had you know over 21 years
of experience of living this and now
he's learning the like called leans
behind these actions behind it so it
actually was more reinforcing to me a
hell of a lot more sense to me
afterwards and so it was a combining of
two men fact when I would assemble a
team to do a consultation for someone in
the country typically I put three at
least two or three case agents that had
operational experience like I did and I
put them with you know in one of my
organizational psychologists that
actually could just validate the science
this solid by what what is we're trying
to do so the collaboration of brains and
brawn kind of to a degree I suppose it's
always you know and at the root of
everything that we're always trying to
do is and someone once asked me to you
know so how do you recruit a spy I said
well first of all you don't and it's
like with any individual and this is
sales as well you know while you're
trying all human beings are trying to do
is they're trying to be affiliated and
validated by people and ultimately human
beings are exceptional
predictable and here's how their
predictable I can always take at face
value that everyone will always act in
their own best interest we're
genetically coded for it we're
biologically coded for it and now my job
is to figure out what you think your
best interests are and one way we do
that is and this is where we do all the
time is I have to figure out what your
priorities are your needs Juan's dreams
aspirations personal professional
long-term short-term and now once I
figure out what your priorities are and
I have resources that will serve those
priorities we're gonna align and that's
and that's where sales comes in that's
where collaboration comes in that's
where relationships build and so what
you're doing is when you know whether
you're talking to a new potential client
or you're trying to recruit a spy all
I'm trying to figure out is what are
your priorities what are your goals and
objectives and what resources do I have
to get you to that point that's the what
so do you want and what can I give you
yeah absolutely
you know with full transparency you know
the biggest thing too is you know I'm I
am 100% anti manipulation or deception
or pretexts or any of these things
because people can pick up on
manipulation or attempts of manipulation
or coercion very rapidly you know that
gives you that creepy feeling you know
when you meet someone you know bad sales
guy trying to sell you something you
pick up on it immediately and so the
best thing you can do is don't have
deception I refuse to lie to you or
deceive or use subterfuge in any way
because it'll blow trust and once Trust
is blown just give up amazing so take us
through the basics of the behavioral
science as as you were applying it in
the field if you would sure so my my
five steps that I realized that I was
doing and usual here's where it came
from I was asked to do an article right
before I got out and it was on you know
what do you what what does
counterintelligence do what does your
team do and I'd never really thought
about it before
um and I goes again when you live
something you just kind of do an act and
so I took that step back and I I gave
myself that optic of what am I actually
doing in all these behavioral
assessments what I was actually doing in
all these cases throughout my career
you know one of the weather was a
recruitment operation and interviewed a
double agent operation false flags I
mean all the fun houki spooky spy stuff
and what I and what I quickly realized
was all I was ever doing was
strategizing trust because I was always
trying to get and hopefully have someone
for moved from point A to point B
hopefully point B would be a place that
that we could collaborate and not on the
on the only way someone is going to move
from A to B and collaborate with you is
through trust and so when I took that
step back and realized Wow and
everything I've ever done in my entire
career and then for the larger optic in
my entire life and it's what we do as
human beings were always strategizing
trust in relationships and so I broke it
down to five really simple steps it's
what I call the elusive obvious you know
so as you said so here's here's the
process it's really simple first what's
your goal what is it you're trying to
achieve and then the second part of that
so so why should they want to you know
why should they want to be interviewed
by you why should they want to co-op
cooperate with you you know why should
they want to do anything and at first
you know that's as surface as I got with
it thinking myself oh it's a very short
term goal but then I asked myself well
why do I want to do that goal where am I
trying to go with this and ultimately in
my work I was trying to protect national
security and ultimately I came out with
what I call the ends goals and means
goals and interviewing someone or
recruiting someone or selling a product
that's really a means to the end and at
the end goal what did you know whether
it's trying to sell the product you're
trying to honor the mission statement of
the company me I was trying to honor
protect the national security of my
country and what was really fascinating
was so many people and things have input
on those means goals you know there's a
lot of relationships that go into this
someone willing to cooperate and trust
you so when I started focusing was on
the end goals first so I reversed and
the end goals for me are very very
simple and easy my number one goal and
every single engagement one is a healthy
professional relationship because
without a healthy professional
relationship everything else will fall
apart I I have become so adamant about
folks and relationships above all else
that I'm I I preach it at every
opportunity I get because you know the
now you always have what I have a group
of a thousand people or two people I
iced I can always say I can guarantee
you not one person is sitting in this
room as successfully as you are without
a relationship with at least one to ten
people because nothing can happen from
that so I always focus on the
relationships first second under that my
next goal is open honest communication
and transparency because you cannot have
a healthy relationship without that
openness communication transparency my
third anchor my third end goal I always
focus on is I make myself an available
resource for the prosperity of others
with no expectation reciprocity and
here's how that breaks down available
resource for others I wasn't offered
someone help and he thought it was
condescending that I was offering help
me thought I thought it was better than
he was and so he took offense to it so
that's why I have available resources
and because human beings do not like
being looked down upon they want to be
treated as equal they want to be
affiliated and valued so I have I offer
resources for their their prosperity
prosperity is a very open term
prosperity according to what may think
prosperity is and thus it in the last
part of this is the low expectation
reciprocity in other words I am being
willing to give my resources to see you
without an expectation a reciprocity in
other words I'm not trying to do this to
get something again as soon as you do
that you start going into the realm of
manipulation shields go up and Trust
goes out the window
so those so those are my three anchors
and that's step one as long as I get set
on those and I move forward then we're
great so step two this is easy discover
their priorities their needs wants
dreams and aspirations short-term
long-term personal professional how do
they depress parity and success from
their point of view because if you don't
talk in terms of their priorities
you're wasting your voice because
everyone will listen to you if you're
talking in terms of what's important to
them so step two is about them step
three understand their context how do
they see the world to their particular
optic without judging it in other words
what's their age their demographic their
ethnicity their gender socioeconomic
status at you know all these things
planning to how people see world to
their particular optic and to that's
generally also where we find places of
affiliation and that we can build upon
one of my favorite questions when
dealing with lots of folks
internationally is you know would you
mind sharing a favorite family holiday
you had growing
and again you don't have to have the
same favorite family holiday but what
you have is a favorite family holiday
everyone has something that remember
from their childhood and when you share
those kinds of things well look I had a
childhood just like yours we had
something we enjoyed we had a tradition
we had a meal we have taste we have
flavors we have music all these things
are where we build those affiliations
and we build that tribe because ancient
tribal man you know a tribe of 30 40 50
it was the first form of survival if you
were not part of a tribe the likelihood
of you passing on your genetic coding to
others was slim to none and so we're
constantly seeking to be affiliated with
meaningful people in our lives and be
valued by them so this is a process by
which we're doing that so that's the
third step for step it's actually this
is where you got to make sure you're
talking in terms of them I want to
suspend your ego and that is you know
you got to put your own thoughts and
opinions aside you got to talk in terms
of them and theirs and never argue
context in other words if they have a
certain point of view that you don't
agree with what's it going to cost you
to not argue it second be non-judgmental
you know because people here's another
guarantee in life if you start judging
them verbally or non-verbally I
guarantee you their shields are going up
because you're basically saying hey
you're not part of my tribe and so
people get defensive and they'll get
shields up
honoring reason and honoring the reasons
really where you want to make sure that
everything you're saying and doing is
congruent with what it is you're trying
to achieve
keep that thoughtful mind engaged don't
get emotionally hijacked where you're
gonna let your emotions interrupt what's
going on between your brain and your
mouth and so honoring reasons I I'm
always asking myself is what I'm about
to do or say going to help or hinder
what is I'm trying to do and ultimately
remember what I'm trying to do is create
a healthy relationship fourth is
validate others you know validation this
is just seeking to understand that a
deep level is possible it's not saying
you necessarily agree with them although
agreeing with them can be validating but
just seek to understand especially if
you have a different political point of
view on religion go anything it is you
know it's not that you're seeking it's
not that you're placating them or
pacifying them know you're seeking to
understand how does they have a certain
point of view the key here is you have
to be congruent with you know what's in
your heart and what's coming out of your
mouth because if you're if you're
language and your verbals are in
congruent you just look like you're you
know you're full of it
so you have to actually be honest
internally about trying to understand
and finally the fifth step of step four
is be generous be generous with your
time and be generous with your resources
and the finally fifth step is crafting
this engagement you know how are you
gonna put all this together to have a
great meaningful you know genuine
sincere conversation and dialogue and so
to do that the first thing I always do
is I'm going to stay this very specific
validation of a strength attribute or
action that I've witnessed in other
words I'm going to it's always be
seeking the greatness and others where
their strengths are so I can always
start out with the conversation about
hey when you did this last week it had
such a great result in this situation
would you mind share with me how you
came up with that would you be willing
to share with others and from there we
just have a great dialogue and
conversation as many other steps to that
but those are the five basic you know
steps I used what I call the elusive
obvious like how do you form a
relationship of trust and health that's
it I get it so it sounds like steps one
through four setting the scene and
coming up with what you're going to say
and then five is delivery is that fair
to say
absolutely and it seems like I think
gancho going based on what I thought
about behavioral analysis I thought that
it would be all step 5 that's probably
my romanticizing a little bit of the of
the spy industry and then a lack of
understanding of just how much stuff
probably goes on behind the scenes with
counterintelligence and that the the tip
of the spear is exactly just that it's
the it's the tiny little bit at the end
that delivers the the message or the
blow or whatever it might be as opposed
to all of the work that's gone before it
you know you did a great job summarizing
it and you could be more right I mean it
really comes down to you have to know
people and how do you know people and
this is this goes back to a lesson I
learned really early on in my career in
the Marine Corps I remember I got ranked
last out of all these other officers and
very humbling moment and I go up to the
the guy at stratum and I said all right
what am I doing wrong
as well you just need to make it about
everyone else about yourself and be a
better leader and I was like oh I
thought I was doing now what the hell
you talking about make it about everyone
but myself how do you do that what's
what's the method I'll make a
conversation about everyone else but
yourself I didn't understand it this
process this is exactly this this is how
you make it about the other person
you're finding out their priorities
you're finding out their context you're
and then how do you put all these things
together to talk in terms of them and
you know you add these four things I'd
love to throw into every statement I
make is one I seek their thoughts and
opinions I talk in terms of our
priorities I validate them
non-judgmentally and I give them choices
when I do one of those four things and
everything I say I write that entire
conversations completely about them I
understand and I'm going to guess that
the science will say that that plays
into a sense of trust and safety and
focus on them as an individual which
I'll presume will probably lower
barriers and stuff like that absolutely
so here's the science behind it
we know this anecdotally because when
you you know when when you say hey when
someone's talking about things that are
important to me I love listening to it
um and we all experience those moments
where we've had these conversations
where you said you had to go in five
minutes but you're like you're there for
10 15 20 30 minutes longer because you
loved the conversation what's because
they're validating you so that's behind
they did a great study at Harvard back
in the spring of 2012 where they
actually wired people's brains up and
what they found was on average people
spend about 40% of their day share in
their own thoughts opinions and ideas
that they have and what they're doing is
they're testing the environment around
them saying hey here's what I think and
here's what I think here's what I think
here's what I think because we're
seeking constantly to see if we can
affiliate with tribes and affiliate with
people and what they found is when
people were sharing their thoughts and
opinions ideas and those thoughts and
opinions and ideas are being validated
by others dopamine was being released in
the brain so the pleasure centers you
know were firings serotonin oxytocin a
blood stream our pleasure centers are
constantly firing when we're being
accepted non-judgmentally for those
thoughts opinions and ideas that we have
because we want to be affiliated with
meaningful groups and organizations for
survival so that's
science behind why when you structure a
conversation dialogue and relationship
like this it's magic
and it's and it the greatest thing -
it's totally genuine there's no you know
I'm anti verbal judo and how to win an
argument I I just there's no strategy on
how to do that it's how do you get to
understand a person and make it about
them okay it's cake I got it I get it so
the the first footsteps that are quite
conceptual I think must require a lot of
research about the person but to me just
seemed like spending time under tension
like work out what it is that the person
wants and how you can speak their
language and give them choices and and
and don't judge but the fifth one I
imagine requires a little bit more
skillfulness well here's how I put it
together here's a generally structure
might and this again I don't have my
notes in from you going off to all my
head what I generally use again step one
is I make a very specific statement of
validation of a strength attribute err
action now that's if I know what one of
those strengths are if I don't I'm gonna
be talk to a stranger do alcohol the
first thing I'm gonna validate is their
time because human beings do not have to
give me their time so I'm gonna be
extremely deferential and gracious for
the time that they can give me and
alford also willing to walk away if they
don't want to engage me because in order
to make this conversation about them you
have to be willing to accept their
denials of your time so I start out with
that next I'm gonna seek their thoughts
and opinions about their priorities
that's step two of my how I strategize
now if I don't know what their
priorities happen to be at this point
because again I haven't had any research
because I do lie I mean we do this in
Salem I'll tell me do lots of cold calls
but the but if you don't know what their
priorities are here's a general priority
of every single human being on this
planet safe - security and prosperity
for them themselves and their families
because that's survival and so Public
Safety is one that I always go to for
the things I was doing but safety
security and prosperity I work with
financial companies all the time that
sell insurance while safety security and
prosperity from them and their families
that's a priority so again if I don't
know what one specific of their parties
are yet one that I can ask them about
and see if and seek their thoughts and
opinions on is it safety security and
prosperity for you and your family
important things you and so that's step
two neta steps the third way I do this
next is I'm gonna validate those
thoughts opinions ideas and that they
just shared with me and validation again
if I don't understand exactly what
they're saying I'll dive a little deeper
so I can get a better understanding now
most of the time what we're trying to do
is we're trying to inspire people to
listen to our thoughts and opinions
ideas I noticed what we're trying to
impart on them and I use that word
inspire because that's really critical
something I realized a number of years
ago is that there's a big difference
between try and then someone of some
want to listen because really you really
can't convince anyone of anything
because that's about you and partying
what you want them to listen to rather
than rather I think of how can I inspire
them to want to listen to me because if
I'm thinking of inspiring you to action
if I'm thinking to inspiring you to
listen or do something in order to
inspire you to do it it's got to be
completely about you and your idea so
how do I inspire you to listen to my
idea this is easy I'm going to ask you
your thoughts and opinions and ideas
about my thoughts and opinions and ideas
another way and another you know say
someone has a certain political point of
view and I say no no no I don't agree
with that here's what I think that's me
trying to convince you of my point of
view and you're not gonna listen as
opposed to they say the same thing I
said I never heard it really quite put
that way before help me understand how
did you come up with that and they share
the thoughts and opinions ideas and I
say well I appreciate that
I was curious what do you think about
this and now I'm seeking their thoughts
opinions about my thoughts and opinions
everyone always wants to plant seeds
with people by you know giving them
thoughts you don't plant seeds with
people by tell them what you think you
plant seeds with people by asking them
what they think and so that's sort
that's where this part of the process is
I ask them the thoughts and opinions
about my idea yes finally well not
finally next I now ask them hey I
understand their priority so I've talked
in terms of my priorities now I offer
them choices of overlapping priorities
now I heard you say this this and this
and I thought this innocent yes do you
think we might be able to work on maybe
XY and Z and now your paradigm a choice
and then finally if appropriate empower
them with choice about remaining in
contact or of assistance that's it
that's this that's the fifth step that's
how I that's how are you line it out and
so when I'm talking to someone live I do
it that way or if I'm going written I
just make sure that at least every one
of those saying
in every single state when I make and
now you've got yourself a spy now you've
caught a spy in there giving up all of
the state secrets and you've got the
Wi-Fi password and everything only it's
only if it's in their best interest to
do so
yeah yes fair point so I wanted to ask
about specific techniques that you guys
use in the field when time is of the
essence so obviously when we're talking
about this kind of a situation it's a
I'm gonna guess there'll be a word for
it like a long a longer game where you
have time to prep but there must be time
you know you were you were in the
service I don't know what particular
department you would have been in it's
911 but you know there's periods of time
where yeah is right New York City during
it yeah oh wow so I mean well first off
can you tell us can you tell us about
that or what what it was like in the
Secret Service when when that was that
was not me
yeah it was it was pretty interesting
matter fact that that my next book
starts out with my my being right there
during it's our office in Manhattan was
about five blocks away from the World
Trade Center oh my god and I heard I was
on a street with a friend of mine
grabbing a cup of coffee and we heard
the first plane hit the North Tower we
looked up and it looks so small compared
to the size of building we thought it
was a small plane that hit and
immediately I my mind and thoughts were
going to boy there's no fog in the air
there's the guy I musta had a heart
attack
and and I went up my floor where I
worked in the building was on the
twenty-fifth floor and so I was up in
you know in our office looking at the
North Tower again like five six blocks
the way the smoke kept getting larger
and larger and spread out more and
finally started seeing what you thought
was debris you know coming down from the
floors in the North Tower and it was
actually people jumping because you
started seeing legs and arms flailing on
the way down and that's what and that's
when the South Tower was hit by the jet
coming from the south and that that
fireball coming through is like you're
watching a you know a movie ends you're
right there so yeah we because again I
worked counterintelligence at the time
and back then we were all in the same
division with the Terrorism division and
the entire office we work nothing but
then terrorism from you know probably
about boy
was from right from September straight
through to December I think it was until
December of 2001 when we actually had
our first day off we were on we were on
shifts at twelve hours on twelve hours
off seven days a week for that entire
time and it it was it was it was like it
was a war zone you know that kind of
exhaustion yeah
because again that's 12 hours Tom twelve
off that didn't that didn't count count
your commute time and it was it was
exhausting but experience my fact that
the first night you know I've you know
on 9/11 I go down to get my car to go
home and I had an engine from the planet
at the South Tower about thirty feet in
front of me because I did flown at our
North before it hit the ground yeah it
was and so our entire time then was
talking to absolutely everyone you know
you just absolute you know the so so
many leads coming in and you just talk
to everyone that might know something I
was and I got involved in so many
different interviews so many different
things during a time for time frame
because every day was a different day
and never knew what you're gonna be
doing I was out of the Fresh Kills
landfill with a rake freaking four
fingers and toes and body parts to try
to give back to family members one day
and another day I'm out at John F
Kennedy Airport pulling someone off of a
British Airways flight that was a name
hit coming in from India but they
thought was a terrorist I mean you had
no idea what you're gonna do every day
oh wow that is that's like a the
equivalent the Secret Service equivalent
of being a dog's body I suppose that
like you know need you washing the coach
early one day and then you delivering
the drinks and then the serving the
Queen and then doing everything yeah it
was a jack-of-all-trades for how no
doubt absolutely yet so I'm with regards
to needing to gain trust or be affected
effing rapidly yes so one copy I don't
put to it anytime you put a time
constraint on having to do something and
you're not having full disclosure of
your time constraint you will be
manipulation and again that's that's
just name the game you know I think have
enough awareness what you're about to do
will keep things good for you so you
don't start rationalizing
what the relationship is because if you
start using manipulative tactics you
don't have a healthy relationship you
have a very short term
you know many manipulation relationship
and so I it's healthy for me to do that
and that now and I also caveat 99.99% of
my time I never had to do that
thankfully but when doing so yeah you
can't there you know using the same
methodologies that I've lined out it
they're exactly the same human beings
will do exactly the same thing now when
you're gaining information there's you
know people ask me all the time about
elicitation how do you elicit
information from people one you can't do
anything without some semblance of trust
and so you will have to develop some
semblance of trust now it's not going to
be it's gonna be one-sided trust because
they're gonna be trusting you and you
even though you're actually viewing them
not in the same view of you know not the
same relationship but they're human
beings have this incessant need to be
great and be correct I think one of the
easiest elicitation techniques are that
people use pretty frequently is what I
call an intentional misstatement so what
that is say something that you aren't
quite sure of blurt it out loud ask them
you know make a statement and they will
correct you it's a guarantee you know
whether you're trying to gain a date of
birth of someone you know just say hey
I'm pretty good at this what are you
born in June I'll go no July oh the 15th
or the 22nd I mean and so right there I
got their date of birth without even
asking a question I mean yeah I can play
that through my mind as well and my
desires to correct she's like coming up
with oh yeah absolutely so you know by
doing that you get a lot of people's you
know priorities you start understanding
their intentions you know so whatever
tidbits of intelligence you've been
tasked with getting you create a
strategy about how you're gonna ask make
an intentional misstep and about that
specific type of intelligence because
most of the time when your are trying to
gather information and whether you're
trying to do you know gather corporate
information you know for you know for
takeovers or you know to outfit the
client you know or whether you're trying
to you know crude crude information for
spies you don't want anyone else to be
alerted to the things that you're
looking for because the guy I said as I
said it earlier if you ask him question
I guarantee you they're gonna think
about that question forever it'll rat
around in their brain so the trick is
don't ask questions about the things
that you care most of the finding out
about
yeah it's planting a flag in the ground
to identify what your priorities are
which is not necessarily what you were
after you wanted dad's right right so
but I'll tell you I my earlier years I
was more into understand and and
exercising that and what I came to find
out was was I got better and better at
getting that the stronger the
relationship and the trust was so I will
I go for the rapid as fast as possible
trust with full transparency which would
guess that for us at that point and then
I just come right it out and asked him
what I want nice and tell him why I need
it and you'd be amazed at how much
easier that is can you can you give us
can you give us an example so I mean I
mean just probably my last couple years
before retired you know we came up and I
won't give you exact details but we came
up with a situation where we identified
an emerging threat to public safety and
they said we need to find a source in
this area and I didn't know anyone but I
went to some of them some of my guys
that you know are my sources of
information I said hey we need someone
in this area they said I don't know but
because that healthy volition for them
and they have healthy relationships well
there's about two weeks later one of my
contacts brings me your potential guy
you know doesn't and you know doesn't
introduce me but gives me his website
gives me an email address and I was like
ah this guy might be right off the you
know right what we're looking for and so
what I did was I looked at his industry
I looked at you know his background and
I I strategize my might and I actually
sent them an email and in the email I
validated his time like I said before I
sought his thoughts and opinions
regarding this specific industry and the
and the threat it might have the public
safety but the same time wants him to
protect his industry from being shut
down if something from Public Safety
went wrong in other words I talked in
terms of his priorities I sought those
thoughts and opinions and I said here's
why it's important to public safety you
know because we want to prevent x y&z
and I said would you be willing to have
a conversation about this if not please
let me know and I'll leave you
completely alone well he called me
looking about I think 15 minutes and I
said hey mr. so-and-so you know if you
wouldn't mind
I'd love to help out because of what you
said it makes a lot of sense it's a
great would you mind if I signed you up
as one of our sources and put you in the
intelligence system and so that people
can benefit from your thoughts and ideas
so we can might protect those people
because okay and there you go
that's as easy it is it wasn't using any
spy craft subterfuge is like hey here's
how you can be a source and here's how
you can help you know protect people
again what a wonder people's general
priories safety protection their of
themselves their families and their
well-being well I like about the
approach that you're describing here is
that it does come from a place of virtue
for the listeners who are regular
they'll know that we're big fans and as
far as I'm concerned truth is a
superpower one of the main reasons that
I like trying to tell the truth as much
as I can although I'm not always perfect
at it is that by telling the truth you
never have to remember what you said
absolutely yeah I mean I went through
understand to cover certification course
years ago and and they said the same
thing you know you have only so many
lies you can tell and then you got to
keep the more lies you tell about who
you are the more you got to keep track
of because one sir out of the bucket you
can't bring them back again and and so I
just got in the habit of not lying and
it was so much easier I just don't like
now if I can't share something with you
big difference we line in my sharing
something and if I can't share something
with you that you want to know I
apologize and tell you why I can't share
because again I have transparency yeah
there's a difference between as Sam
Harris describes it in his book lying he
says there's a difference between lies
of omission and lies of comission and I
think that that's identified quite
nicely there so we've talked about being
on broadcast what about when you're on
receive are there some strategies that
people can use to identify people that
are untrustworthy or people who have an
alternative agenda and you know you
watch these stories of these programs
like lie to me and stuff like that way
you've got these incredibly proficient
guys for anyone who hasn't seen it the
the main protagonist is able to detect a
modicum of disgust at his stepmothers
death because and that means that he did
it because his eyes flicked up and to
the left and all of this kind of crazy
stuff and we're gonna guess that the
level of fidelity is not quite that high
but that there must be some some sort of
guys in the service who do have some
pretty crazy skills like that
so I I'm very good friends with a few of
them one of my best friends is Joe
Navarro world-renown owns a body
language expert and he'll be the first
to tell you as well well you the best
people in the world including Joe can
only detect deception 50% of the time
the person accuracy use a nonverbal
detection alone because it simply
doesn't work because what you do is if
you're gonna use non verbals and i do i
you and what you're looking for is
you're not looking forward to set of
indicators you looking for stress
indicators because lying is stressful
but also remembering negative thoughts
and and events can be stressful as all
and so our nonverbals will indicate
comfort from stress and so i'm looking
for in my cause and comfort on the cause
and stress um but again that's a whole
separate topic to get into but when so
basically as i heard you asked the
question i get this a lot too how do i
how do I make sure I'm not being taken
advantage of or I'm not being
manipulated or tend to be manipulated
correct yes this is this one is really
easy because I get this lot so I just
someone say to me so Robin what do you
do if someone's trying to manipulate you
and my first response when someone asked
me that the first time it kind of
befuddled me because I said to myself
wow it's never happened and they said
well how does it never happen I said
well this is easy because if I'm always
looking for a healthy relationship and
healthy relationships are based on open
honest communication transparency if you
are actually communicating something me
that I don't understand because there's
omission or there's blank spaces and I
asked you a question for clarification
transparency and you don't give it I
just stopped engaging you because you're
obviously not looking for a healthy
relationship and it's okay with me again
I don't hold resentment against it I
just understand that alright you your
agenda is different than mine and if I'm
looking for transparency you're not
willing to give it that I'm not willing
to keep engaging with you and so my only
advice to people is don't be afraid to
ask clarifying questions if you don't
understand something if people are
talking fast or they're using words and
terms or situations you don't quite
understand ask for clarification
apologize you know self-deprecating
humor and ask for that clarification if
they can't give it to you I'm I become
skeptical of the the priorities that
they have you know the goals that they
have I don't think they're gonna be
really congruent with
came out of their mouth especially if
someone gives you that creepy car
salesman you know feeling it's because
they're there in congruent with the
words that are coming out our mouths so
what they're actually feeling towards
you yeah I guess that's that's kind of
like the canary in the coalmine for all
of this right if you if there's just
something that you don't understand
that's a byproduct of omission on their
side or a lack yup it's some sort of
disjointedness within the conversation
and then that can be counteracted by you
asking and then if the follow-up it's
like the little hurdle that you're
asking them to step over and if they
can't get over that hurdle it's right
probably because that they don't want to
I suppose right you stated it perfectly
absolutely so I just don't engage with
because again in that situation I take
people very specific you know it doesn't
mean I can't trust them in another
situation but in this specific situation
are the things that we're talking about
no we're not gonna have a healthy
engagement here so I'll just disengage
it sounds an awful lot like being quite
frank and quite upfront not almost not
blase in but certainly certainly very
upfront and and as transparent as you
can be both in terms of what you are
trying to what you're trying to convey
and what you do and don't understand is
forming a quite a big basis here and I
suppose that the foundation for a
relationship of trust is truth are in
two directions right in openness yeah
you know and because you said you know
very frank and and it is it can be very
frank but same time though it's very
extremely cordial because it's always
about them you know there's never me and
it's never me inflicting my thoughts and
opinions on you about you I don't judge
you I don't say hey I'm just being
honest just what you're an ass you know
that's that's that's not the thing you
do it's it's about being being frank and
open about what my intentions are and
try and understand yours only because
that's that's it yeah I get that so I
wanted to pick your brains as far as the
classifieds
broadcaster will allow us to just get
some stories from your time while you're
in the survey
and the first thing that's come to mind
for me is who do you think on the planet
has the best behavioural agents would
you say that the the u.s. is really good
other the Russians happen to be
fantastic at it boy everyone's you know
I wouldn't put it down with service
because services and services across all
countries have have greatness and have
and have channel inside each of those
services that has the patience and the
focus of trust on and put the input the
broader need of the country ahead of
their personal need for
self-gratification and glory and I've
seen that in every service I've worked
with I've seen some fantastic Russian
officers I've seen some Russian officers
I've seen some fantastic American CIA
and FBI agents and some horrible ones
and age doesn't matter it comes down to
does this person put in the mission of
the country ahead of themselves and do
they have the patience to develop
healthy trusting relationships the
people that can do that I don't care
where you're from those are the ones
that win because they're winning for a
greater cause that's it it I've seen it
everywhere yeah I totally get that so
how about when I'll give you one group
that most I was really really impressed
with um they were the united states army
green berets I worked with them a couple
years back and the most different thing
about them is that they were very much
like my career my career was what it was
not because of me anything except opera
just chance it really was chance I was I
worked operations for 21 years I did the
same type of operations for 21 years
you're going to either get good or get
out and you know and a lot of times in
all these other organizations you'll do
it for a couple years on a street then
you promote into management and up and
up and up and so you you're no longer
doing the actual craft on the ground and
you and you're going to lose it because
one you never mastered it to begin with
and two you don't do it anymore I I was
very fortunate that I I did it for a
number of years then I was on the team
and ran the team for a couple years
still doing it
um and then I went back and did it four
or five more years before I retired I
mean it was non-stop constantly
strategizing and strategizing learning
about what and that's why I'm so
altruistic about this because ultimately
came down to people just want healthy
relationships so they can survive that's
it
now how do I faster that and so and what
I mentioned the Green Berets they spend
this one particular group spent their
entire career doing exactly the same
thing that's that's you're gonna get mad
skills at anything you do if you do it
for that long yeah it's just it's just
so so services that allow their people
to continually hone practice refine and
get best at their craft over years
they're gonna be the best you end up
with some some real beasts at the end of
the I suppose yeah you really do and the
greatest thing is there's you calling
the real beasts these are the ones that
are actually the genuinely good people
in life because they know the cause and
effect of behaviors they know that it's
all comes down to relationships and
trust and there's no these are the ones
that aren't playing games with people
anymore I like that I I know people
every now and then will say hey when
we're going out to dinner once you you
know talk to that waitress to get her
date of birth and her pin number and I'm
like it's like it's like dude do you
understand I don't I don't play with
people I just refuse to play with people
I I honor people too much they and I on
our relationships and health and and
being a good human being too much to
play with people there's some other some
agents that you've met who was
sufficiently talented to be able to like
if if they decided to put their foot to
the floor so to speak would be able to
be able to do some things like that and
really kind of use use these to get some
surprising results out with people oh
god yeah I mean I saw I got a friend of
mine Chris Haag naggy social engineer
and actually I'm a board member on the
innocent lies foundation with him he
uses all his technical and cyber skills
to protect companies and then we took it
to the next level and we're protecting
human trafficking with children around
the world and years ago we put together
a social engineering course where he
certified people as social engineers in
other words can these people go in and
hack information from human beings and
get these these the type of information
that can compromise country companies so
that we can educate that company on
protecting themselves against more
like us you know better that are
actually have nefarious things in their
minds because yeah if yeah these these
pills used by the bad guys that's why
that's why there are hackers that's why
there are you know data mines that get
you know stolen all the time because it
comes down to human beings and these
techniques and the difference is is that
those people are manipulating and have
an agenda and generally agendas are on
timelines
and so that's why I'm a choice about
maintaining contact or assistance is all
use one of my fail safes that make sure
this is a manipulative also no
expectation reciprocity that's my also
one but these people the bad guys
they're doing exactly the same thing
they just have an agenda the good thing
is though people with agendas tend to be
much more impatient than people have
actually gone for healthy relationships
so in patience you can see through
impatient and very rapidly that's so
cool I love the term social engineer as
well it really does sound like a haka
taken off the computer and into the real
world that's what they do I mean these
guys are phenomena Chris and his team
you know are phenomenal at this and they
have they have competitions you know and
when they go to blackhat every year it's
pretty fascinating when we had two
classes out there and you Chris about to
have another class now down in Florida
you know we send people you know teams
out you know to engage people elicit
information and practice how to do this
again no you know no no personal ID and
you know personal identifying
information right then be compromised or
anything like that just how do you
practice engaging with a stranger and
developing rapid trust yeah I guess
watching those guys at work must be
pretty fascinating and terrifying in
equal measure it it becomes you know you
when you're because then what's come
down to you're watching the elusive
obvious what are they doing they're
making it all about the other person
it's really pretty
it's real pretty simple if you know how
to get out of yourself and out of your
own ego yeah so one thing that keeps on
coming to mind for me as well as
obviously you will have been a part of
the agency through not quite through a
digital revolution but certainly through
digital surgeons I suppose did that and
has that made a new body of information
obviously how much how much work is now
done online and electronically versus
face-to-face that was huge you know
government organizations are generally
light years behind everyone else and
ours was definitely one of them hello
that hard to get moving right like you
you've got yeah thousands and thousands
of people that you need to drag along
with you it's gonna take some time to
get them up to speed so we over to a
paperless system 2011 to 2013 ish
maybe 2010 ish and I thought this would
never work I mean we were so entrenched
with putting a hard piece of paper and
into a supervisor's inbox to wait for a
signature to get it back to put in a
file with nothing but a big fat thing of
paper in a wall and I said this is never
gonna work and I'll tell you what by the
time you know within a couple years I
mean by the time I left I I never
touched a piece of paper for years
everything was electronic man it sounds
so [ __ ] prehistoric I know the here's
a thing that's gonna happen and there's
a guy with a pen and he's gonna sign it
they probably couldn't even find a pen
now the other thing too is funny too we
moved on to believe or not when I first
came in we used to sign time sheets and
we used to have different colored
pencils for the different kinds of hours
we worked and so we had had the right
colored pencil when we're filling in our
time sheet for the tape the next cue
especially for the FBI I wouldn't have
thought that they would have had so yeah
like that yeah time sheets yeah time
sheets are big and they finally got rid
of that and I went electronic - yeah
that was that was pretty funny
that's hilarious so before we wrap up
Robin I wondered if there were any
stories that you have that come to mind
that you think might interest the
listeners anything that you've been
thinking about recently or any
situations with other friends or with
past experiences for yourself
huh yeah I think the world's a pretty
interesting place right now that's
that's that's one thing moving forward
what do you think the role of
intelligence officers will be as we as
we go forward oh it's definitely
continuing it has to be you know you
know you can only do so many things
through a computer although using the
same communication strategies through
computers and emails I do it all the
time and it's very effective the you're
always gonna need someone that's that
tip of the spear though do you think
we're never gonna be able to just
absolutely guys the absolutely but you
know we have we have hundreds of
thousands of years of evolution that I
say we develop trust in one way it's not
gonna get wiped out you know in a
generation that went cyber it's it's
genetically you can't have it happen
that's why you know you think about
Facebook or Twitter or Instagram or any
of these you know social media platforms
people are looking for likes well why
they looking for likes they're looking
for followers because that's validation
so no my my anecdote is it probably
takes you about a thousand likes equal
one person saying good job in life in
life presence so again these things are
great I got to tell you they're
fantastic tools and I love them to death
but still one-on-one dialogue
communication and Trust and and having a
healthy relationship that way because
you're able to look at everything is
coming at you're able to hear the words
the visual cues the Nonnberg the
nonverbal cues all these things become
very congruent with in my form and a
healthy relationship is this is this
genuine and you can you can do an awful
lot without that but you're never gonna
take it over an edge with it so that
must be quite that must be quite
reassuring as opposed to a degree that
there's this kind of this kind of like
you know / ceiling and I remember
listening to Sam Harris talk about the
impact the upcoming impact that virtual
reality will have and he talked about
this kind of cognitive ceiling you could
you could argue as you've kind of
alluded to there where there's only so
far in terms of persuasion that a flat
screen in in your hand or in front of
you on a computer will be able to take
you however
the more immersive you make that
experience the higher that ceiling is
going to become raised so with things
like VR and now these these newer
programs where they can take like five
minutes of you on me speaking and then
completely recreate whatever they want
with the words and the phrases and the
cadence that we've been speaking in
that's that's a pretty scary thought it
is you know I I'm not one of these guys
that says oh it's always better than
back this way or it was much you know
the good old days kind of guys I love I
love watching the advances of things but
every time you have a new breakthrough
in something it confuses things Society
will be confused because of our coding
our genetic and biological coding
they'll they'll jump to it they'll bills
seeking and immediate gratification
you know intellectually from it in some
way whatsoever and then and then the
brain's gonna get confused for a while
until they figure out how to actually
make it a functional tool that actually
aids life because it takes a lot every
time every time is a new jump forward in
anything there's always a stumbling
period we're trying to figure out how
how this actually interact with with
this miraculous thing between our two
years that has is really the most
advanced advanced thing we'll ever see
in our lifetime is this brain it's
pretty remarkable it's crazy isn't it I
guess the pace of changes well the fact
is that society is able to move so much
more quickly than our brains are and the
most stupid thing is that even if our
brains were able to catch up even if you
gave it like a decade to catch up it'd
still be so far behind it'll be almost
pointless you're like I don't need you
like ten years ago I didn't need my
brain to be able to use a Filofax I
needed it to be able to use a Blackberry
and in ten years time I won't need to
use Instagram I need e t--'s whatever
whatever's coming next in a decade I
still can't understand how I couldn't
get anything done 20 years ago you know
with nothing but a pad of paper and a
paper calendar I'm a desk I have no idea
how you live with that a Google Calendar
or scheduling or constant communication
with the world I have no idea how guy
anything done before and then then you
bring it up to now I have no idea how I
get so much done now because having
because I could never I could not have
possibly done all this kind of stuff 20
years ago
what L do I do all my time it's really
it's that it's fascinating to think
about it must feel like or it must have
felt like looking back on your career
now and like I say having seen the both
sides of this kind of digital surgeons
to a degree it must almost feel like two
different jobs it's interesting it does
and I'll give you an algae it's it's
like a it's like a sense you know like
one of our five senses I remember I did
a trip but I won't say what country I
went to cuz I don't want disparage
anyone but we did this overseas trip and
you know we went into their command
center where they have all their
analysts it inside this command center
and they had so much technological
capabilities um with following people in
their own country like the spies in
their own country that they I remember
one of them said that yeah it was a bad
day if we only have 95 percent of this
person's day covered or we knew what
they were doing
95 they knew what this guy was doing 95
percent of the time their technological
coverage and they asked and they asked
that's nice like and I was like maybe
ten percent of the day we know what
they're doing and but you know what the
challenge was they could recruit sources
they had a very very hard time using
interpersonal skills to actually get
human bodies recruited and so they were
massively behind in a lot of areas
because one of their senses was enhanced
the technological sense but their other
sense of interpersonal skills was
completely thrown out because they
relied too heavily on the other there's
some compensator e mechanism yeah right
and us rrrm personal skills tend to be
higher because our Constitution and
keeps us from doing hey it's good like
that when you skin when your skin you
need to rely on your skills don't you
you can't be you can't be spending
absolutely on things interesting
statistic I was watching a Amazon
documentary recently and they said that
if you took the data that was collected
on everybody on the earth and you
printed it on an a4 piece of paper
double-sided a4 piece of paper every
day's worth of data that gets collected
would go from here to the Sun and back
four times
the stack of paper of data that is
collected on a daily basis and most of
its just garbage gobbledygook to do with
like location data and how many bytes of
this and what address with it sent to so
on and so forth but that's the volume of
data that to the Sun and back four times
I just thought I thought I thought that
was unbelievable yeah and there the
another statistic that they dropped was
that the malleus thing to do with how
efficient it is and you were talking
earlier on about having the paper going
in and out and all this sort of stuff if
you were to remove all of the hardware
and just have the electrons so the the
actual atoms that are containing the
information that the internet and all of
all of the collective human knowledge
electronically is held on it would be
about the size and the weight of an
orange
so you think they've got everything
everything and all of the banks and
banks of computers and the servers at
Google and all of this even the hard
driving house and it's like just an
orange that's all you've got
yep mumbling innit yeah really and then
you compare that with to the Sun and
back four times a day and yeah you know
I think it's probably a pretty big
credit to yourself and also the guys
that you worked with that you were able
to survive and adapt through that
particular period because it must have
been super turbulent um and you know
it's like anything you to get on board
or get out and it really I really kept
that I really try to keep things as
basic as possible and they did there was
everyday there is always there always
man I'm so sick of systems getting
updated and it usually you know I got a
credo in life if it ain't broke don't
fix it will they hell it nothing was
broke and they fixed it every day anyway
drove me up a wall so Robin can you tell
the listeners about your books please
and why they can find you online yeah
sure um so first let's you find me
online that's easy my website is
www.pevs.com all one word people formula
I'm on LinkedIn obviously Twitter's a
[ __ ] reek RDR e ke follow me there I
don't post a whole lot and I don't take
is the other thing too I never take
sides I just take science
and human human interactions because
here's another guarantee in life take a
side half the world will line up against
you I don't like that and then so my
books I have one my first book came out
years ago called it's not all about me
the top ten techniques for quick rapport
and Godot on Amazon in any country
that's a short read about 20,000 words
my last book that came out it's called
to go to trusts in American counter
intelligence experts five steps lead to
succeed that's also all over the place
that was with st. Martin's Press great
publisher I worked with there and then
my next book coming out the it's it's on
behavioral analysis and it's it's the
six signs that you can actually judge
what you can trust someone or not
actually and more likely it's predict
their behavior and we're still working
on the title right now was what was our
current working title ah just slipped my
mind we've had about three or four
Elizabet working titles I love the the
journey that things go through like when
we were coming up with the with the
title for this podcast and I went
through like this six month period while
I was like pre recording shows and doing
things I want to look back I went back
through my notes not so long ago I'm
going through and I was thinking what
the [ __ ] were you thinking but just
looking at all of these raizy names and
it's because after a while it's kind of
like the name of a pet right like the
book your your book names will roll off
your tongue as if it was you is if it
was a child's name but during the
process you look at the words with such
like high fidelity like is that even a
word anymore does it doesn't sound like
a word it doesn't look like a word
actually just remembered it's called
sizing people up it's what it's called
right now it probably will be too it's
probably gonna want to be in sizing
people up um what if it's a man and it
will know we'll know that you've had a
you've got a creative wobble another
creative Wow oh well that's a good
description of it too that created
wobbles every day yeah
back and forth Robin man it's been
absolutely fascinating I'd love to get
you back on again soon as I'm sure that
the absolutely will be very interested
to to see what comes out with the next
book and
good luck finishing it off hey thanks
about to shade of Chris and thanks for
all your time
[Music]